but first using and abusing the troops
that's the focus of tonight's angle
it seems like only yesterday doesn't it
when the democrats were worried about
deploying the military against antifa
and the blm mobs who were rampaging
across our cities last summer
misused our american military for
basically his political campaign totally
unable to unite us as a country
he is misusing military and governmental
assets
it is not the role of the u.s military
to go into cities and states
and undermine local law enforcement
president trump
has degraded
the independence of the military and
ignored
some of the dangerous tendencies of
political activity within the military
well those same democrats now have had a
change of heart liberal d.c mayor muriel
bowser
announced that 5 000 national guardsmen
will remain
in dc through at least march now this is
down from that obscene number of 25 000
who were called up after the january 6
capital riot
now did they really think that that
insane
animal skin guy was planning to return
to dc with other furry fiends
to make a stand i don't think so
this is all political theater directed
by democrat leadership
with a horrible edge they're using the
military right now to ratchet up the
drama
of their kangaroo impeachment trial of
former president trump and the true
presence it allows these liberals to do
what they do best
play the victim despite evidence of
any serious ongoing threat and it
furnishes them with a backdoor way to
execute their next agenda
item purging the military of any
political opponents
now according to the hill democrats will
accomplish this by
inserting language into this year's
national defense authorization act
to address extremism at the pentagon and
other federal agencies
we know that some groups actively
attempt to recruit our personnel into
their cause
or actually encourage their members to
join the military for the purpose of
acquiring skills and experience
a senior pentagon official told
reporters earlier this month
now of course this is all kind of vague
for a reason the broader and more
opaque the language the easier it is to
cancel military members and other
government personnel
who don't fall in line politically or
even culturally
now most people would agree that
generally dangerous extremists
should not be allowed to serve and join
in the military of course we don't want
members of
of say isis and betting themselves in
our ranks
obviously kkk of course not but
that's not really who the democrats are
talking about
when it's come to white extremist groups
domestic terrorists somehow we find
ourselves unable to address those troops
the fear that other americans president
trump's
supporters will harm their fellow
americans some of them far-right
extremists with whom president trump has
been playing footsie for years
what is the definition of the republican
party right now or are there several
there are several but unfortunately the
largest right now i think is trump
loyalist
and part of that trump loyalist faction
is true
conspiracy theorists and kooks and
extremists
trump loyalists wow they want to fuel
the narrative that
not only is your conservative neighbor
or family member
untrustworthy suspicious and potentially
seditious
but that the military itself is full of
right-wing extremists
ready to rise up at a moment's notice
to rid our ranks of racist and
extremists
and to create a climate where everyone
fit and willing
has the opportunity to serve this
country with dignity
the job of the department of defense is
to keep america safe from our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
okay just take that in for a moment
our secretary of defense says the
pentagon with its
bloated budget cannot provide for the
national defense
unless it carries out essentially
purges of undesirables within the
military ranks
forget the fact that china is a poise
for global domination it's likely to
take taiwan forget about that
the rise of domestic violent extremism
is a serious and growing national
security threat
the biden administration will confront
this threat with the necessary resources
and resolve
the first is a tasking from president
biden sent to the odni today
requesting a comprehensive threat
assessment coordinated with the fbi
and dhs on domestic violent extremism
this assessment will draw on the
analysis from across the government
and as appropriate non-governmental
organizations
what non-governmental organizations
is she talking about exactly that are
going to report on their fellow
americans
the aclu black lives matter planned
parenthood
anti-gun rights organizations i mean
presumably they think anyone who
disagrees with their far left goals
are extremists now from what we've
already heard the abide administration
say it's clear that they're going to use
the power
and surveillance of the us government to
keep
tabs on a lot more people than we ever
would have thought would have been
embedded in government agencies as
domestic terrorists
yeah law-abiding americans who maybe
the party in power think they're getting
out of line
as a part of this the nsc will undertake
a policy review effort
to determine how the government can
share information better about this
threat
support efforts to prevent
radicalization disrupt violent extremist
networks and more
sharing information well some democrats
are already pushing an even broader
ideological purge of the entire national
security apparatus
now earlier this month congresswoman
stephanie murphy proposed a bill
to keep trump's supporters from holding
security clearances
she did this by asking applicants
whether they participated in the january
6
2021 activities at the u.s capitol or a
similar stop to steel activity
and the precise role they played at such
activity
even if it does not constitute a
criminal offense
attendance at an event designed to
delegitimize the results of a
presidential election
and prevent the peaceful transfer of
power raises serious questions about an
applicant's suitability
for a security clearance wow
president xi jinping would be very proud
drive out all political opposition drive
them
underground force everyday americans to
live in fear
encourage neighbor to snitch on neighbor
family to snitch on family
american against american my friends the
message is clear
if you're a conservative who has any
questions about election irregularities
then you better shut up if you want to
keep your job
first amendment forget about it
which makes it all the more ironic that
it's being cheered on by the media
i do think we have a problem with
infiltration in law enforcement in the
military
and it's going to take a while for us to
both de-radicalize
and remove those elements from positions
of authority
this screening needs to happen across
the entire military
and we should be removing people that
are members
even if they are not active members
because it's really against their oath
of office
you can't stand by idly and see people
in uniform whether it's law enforcement
or military have q anon patches on
this is absolutely poisonous for the
country
republicans have to stand up and stop
democrats
from targeting our active duty military
personnel
or our vets these men and women have
endured
oftentimes repeated tours of duty abroad
risking life and limb many times coming
back to destroyed families
and now they're viewed with suspicion
and targeted by elected officials at
home
republicans need to step up in unison
and demand that the defense department
and the bidet administration
clearly define what they think
constitutes
extremism now if a member of the
military voted for trump
does that make him an extremist now what
if someone complains on facebook that
the federal government wastes a lot of
money
is she an extremist what if they say
that roe vs wade should be overturned
or what if they participate in the march
for life
what if they're conservative baptists
they believe that sex outside of
marriage is immoral
is that extremist what if they have guns
at home
and they're lifetime nra members will
they now
be considered extremists or even
terrorists
we deserve to know
you see where this is destined to lead
and it is certainly not to a freer
and more united america and that's the
angle